life for so many feels like it's on hold
but helplessness and uncertainty have
haunted nick talbert for the past
three years this rural farm in ohio
is not where he expected to be living it
was like my entire future had just been
taken away
in one moment over social media for no
good reason
that moment was a tweet by president
trump in july 2017
stating that transgender people would no
longer be allowed to serve
in the u.s military including nick
this ban treats transgender people as
lesser people
this ban implies that we are not as
worthy we are not as capable and none of
that is true at all
so this one was taken during a weekend
field training exercise
at the time of the tweet nick was
planning a future serving his country
when his president took that future away
nick decided to fight
in court trump's policy was delayed
but not defeated this has been an
absolute roller coaster for me
emotionally
physically in my personal life
there are just so many unknowns tell me
about your reaction when you found out
that biden had won
it was like a huge sigh of relief for me
i'm proud of the coalition we put
together the broadest
and most diverse coalition in history
gay straight transgender white latino
asian
joe biden has promised to allow
transgender people to serve openly
in the military and increase protections
for the lgbtq
community discrimination is still
rampant
in this country and lgbtq people
particularly transgender and gender
non-conforming people
are often the targets of that i don't
think it is going to take long
at all for people to feel the effect of
an administration that
actually cares about all americans
but biden's ambitions could be derailed
by two
upcoming elections that will determine
which party controls the senate
the house has already passed legislation
that would make any kind of
discrimination against the lgbtq
community illegal but republican senate
leaders stop the bill from progressing
any further biden has said that passing
the equality act
would be a priority in his first 100
days in office
but he needs the senate on side and if
republicans hold the power
they may be reluctant to support a law
that could anger many deeply religious
americans
without blanket legislation condemning
discrimination against the lgbtq
community
the courts have to decide whose rights
are most at risk
and thanks to president trump the top
court in the country
has a much more conservative lineup i
think that when the bride administration
makes its policies it's going to have to
be aware that
there's a judiciary that has a very
broad view of what the free exercise of
religion means
and so if they do certain things they
would have to worry that their
decisions would be overwritten by the
courts but possible battles in the
courts or
congress will not dampen nick's dreams
i'm really hoping that with the new
presidency
we can finally get some solid answers
and i can finally start to move on and
be a real adult
he hopes he won't have to wait too long
becky kochel sky news lisbon ohio